[Music]
three two one action
hey guys welcome back to hop the record
where we talk about whatever we want and
today we have Lauren back you guys keep
let me come back good good
sorry you get the red cap yet Starbucks
Starbucks we're talking some Starbucks I
tried my dog dragged poop around the
whole house oh that does have so you
woke up to get the red cup but you
couldn't get it cuz your dog drives all
over that I don't know what the answer
is better here if I say yes how did that
happen to the dog poop inside the house
and stepped on it no he so we had a yard
and we don't always clean up the poop
immediately okay okay okay
and I guess he just like ran through it
into and we have like a bedroom door
like right and anyway so he comes in the
bedroom and it was all over his paws
like in between his paws I didn't notice
it but he get on the carpet yes Oh
thankfully is mostly a wood floor but
then there are some carpet and I like
kicking him down by your bed nothing do
my sister used to have a yard and now
when I go to her house I look out the
sign-in door because she has three dogs
I look at this on the door and I'm just
like damn toilet it's gone dude it's
gone so the red cup wasn't enough for
you to just go [ __ ] it I'm gonna get it
anyways I don't leave lines well she had
a shitty morning good no cuz there's
times with that because I want to talk
to and then like depending on what I'm
trying to do I'll be like [ __ ] it I'll
clean this [ __ ] up later mmm when do you
do that at times I've never told you but
always get some stuff in real time to do
so much [ __ ] on the show what do you
mean you clean it up later you'll clean
up the [ __ ] in your yard later well oh
yeah that's come on many times
exposition that's what I want to know
this is a bit this is a bit
times sometimes I'll come out and I'll
see a pile of dog [ __ ] in the kitchen
and I looked at it and I'm like or I
could pretend like I didn't see it and I
just go to the gym clean it up but it's
a bit it's never happened before
yeah just inside the bit space yeah yeah
no inside so well since we're talking
bits sometimes I'll seek a throw up and
I'm like see things so I'm like he is
[ __ ] dumb and he is very blind you
can't talk safely about bits anymore yes
God I mean real talk I definitely ignore
the trash like nah that's not a bit I
just pretend like I didn't see it and
wait for China to get out I actually
ignore the cat poop sorry kitty
you do yeah the cat poop in the cat
vomit okay look I get it when a man does
it not a bit it's a bit one perfect
person I don't know what to say about
you guys you guys are trash people I see
things I clean it up I know for a fact
you ignore throat sometimes not with the
facts man okay so one Tuffy so one time
I heard her on the phone and it was in
an area she was always in the same room
and then I walked in that room
and it was the cat throw up in the
middle of the [ __ ] floor it probably
did it yeah mum on the phone she's like
doing a [ __ ] she's doing a lap around
it
sorry I'm busy a businesswoman no
putting bread on the table for family no
way she helped out a little bit we're
not to be ignorant but like why is there
so much Catherine what's going on cats
just throw up I'm like Danny yeah they
get hair balls and so like sometimes it
like blocks their I don't know their
digestive system and then they just they
throw up the hairball then they throw up
the food you know when I was younger I
thought the hair balls would literally
be kind of like those dust bunnies that
you see in the corner or light or not oh
no there's a little egg and gross it
looks like a poop like a wet piece of
those it's so quiet it's easy to pick up
it's not at least not my cat it's like
slimy it's easier to pick up the poop in
the throw-up wait till it hardest
she's waiting for it to heart smarty
married on the carpet that's what I'm
doing I went in for it to heart and
wants it to coagulate understand it's
the bit does it's for the I want to
harden in the mid-span as well
I thought your Halloween costume stuff
and they're cracking me up like the
nunya business or something so she was
dressed up as a nun and then her husband
was dressed up in a business suit that's
good no I spent $400 in Amazon and
returned them all oh I only bought the
wine Amazon if you're watching yeah I
only bought the costumes that I knew I
could return mmm that's smart
I always think I'm gonna return it and
then I convinced myself that I'll
probably need it one day yeah so then I
justified and I have to way too much to
my closet like so many costumes do you
think that too like a hard up hasn't had
sex in this whole life like priests guy
a sexy nun is just enough like he just
looked at a nun he's like God Diane
please more into like little boy not sex
there in sexy little boy cos all truth
oh damn the altar boy do you think they
put the boys in the nun costumes oh I
haven't heard that one either
yeah the costumes from fashion of us I
don't know it's like priests or shopping
in fashion oh oh true they don't even
they have no fashion sense
I heard you guys are taking prenatals
that's a big step so so what so she's
taking for the vitamins that's a huge
step because that usually means you're
prepping for something baby I don't know
just wants healthier Harry's wanted
healthy hair and nails yeah also a Steve
came to me Ron during ovulation week but
you know like oh [ __ ] Carrie he came he
came inside
when was this one was vagina last week
two weeks ago two days did you marinate
I did I did you oh yeah I don't know I
fell asleep after in a start small yeah
that's that was my plan so like who
should take a pregnancy test right now
I could I don't know if like cuz you
have to wait for the aid to drop before
the sperms like get in there so it could
happen anytime this week or it could not
happen I was drinking wine all day
yesterday so I think it's okay well I I
got pregnant in London and we were doing
like wine tasting that whole trip and I
was already pregnant at this manacled
character that's so sick it wasn't that
cool cuz have you guys been to a hotel
in London we don't have you been in a
hotel in London yes er so the beds are
kind of like it's pretty wedding really
small like a twin size bed is actually
this wide yeah so we pushed our beds
together to make the baby
well were you asked for a king-size they
just give you two twins and they expect
you to push it together yeah I'm like I
get that it's the same size but like you
do the work this is good or if you get a
king-size bed it's just two kings
underneath one two twins underneath one
big sheet yeah all the kings in Europe
are twins Europe get it together
I mean had actual kings this you know
this [ __ ] it would make sense of who
they did that here I'm surprised Steve
remembered London we don't because you
were so jet-lagged and angry like you
know he was like really [ __ ] the whole
time you're a [ __ ] I can't even
imagine it well it was because I was so
[ __ ] jet like I wasn't even myself I
straight-up walked out on a restaurant
on him like I walked out of the
restaurant and left him in a restaurant
with [ __ ] and Amsterdam
just like cranky it took I'm hangry
you haven't had a monster yeah yeah yeah
it's like a freaky [ __ ] call bro yeah
I'm in a real mood now I'm a mood I was
in Italy for the first time maybe like a
month ago with an adderall prescription
that is like a game
did you travel even harder yeah I went
out all the tours I learned all the
things I was up at 4 a.m. exploring the
city do you know cool Europe is in the
morning before the tourists come out
that's the way to do it yeah well like
I've never tasted not tasted I never try
it at my whole life um I don't know it
just makes you want to wake up and do
things do you need to like take it the
minute you wake up to feel that or do
you take it before you go to sleep
definitely don't take a prettier sleep
no it takes like 30 minutes kick in so
Steve read a bunch of scripts [ __ ] yeah
dude part if I gave you at all you would
you would build a house out of Legos
this you would go outside it'd be like
barred bullet guest house our [ __ ]
later should we take it for our next
riders retreat that could be tight
actually are you kidding me I'm so
scared that before you take it like
chair in the middle yeah yeah I like
that I'm down Oh that'd be sick not with
like four scripts yeah you take it and
then clean the house it doesn't work
imagine gel on it he'd probably just be
like ready dude huge space he would be
so focused on spacing out it's for
people that have that it makes them
focus but people that don't have a TV
it just makes you really you really
you'll like do legit focus on what it
ever it is that you want to do it could
be like I just like shots online way too
much I once like when I first started
taking a year years ago I like I think I
like mash me at six times oh that's
funny well is that what was the climax
like it was just like the regular it was
the same it was like I just didn't stop
did you know that it was going until I
had six there's one after the other I'd
be the other after the other I like my
clothes it was a like a window where
like whatever you whenever you take it
the last thing you're doing is that's
what you go on I don't know I think it's
that's what it seems like because I go
tell you like I want to take it and cook
right but then like let's see you start
cooking and then all of a sudden yeah
like you'll have 87 pies
you go through the trash pick up the
trash now enjoy like crazy or you're
like I'm gonna pet my dog right now and
then you end up going to get license in
massage for your dog and you're like
[ __ ] do it all kinds of techniques
that nobody think was possible
yeah yeah is like that like no I think
it just makes you it like for me it
lifts my mood to my psychiatrist is like
I don't know why it does that that's
really weird I don't know I was like it
makes me like people like but it just
like put you in a good mood to be like
oh I want to take out the trash
oh I want to work on my script I want to
do all these things that an hour ago oh
that's true that is true I didn't think
about in the context because I was
thinking about you're talking about
masturbating six times I hung up on that
and she doesn't masturbate shame on me
oh is that what you guys have a thing
right it makes it more intense if you
don't masturbate it's very nice it's
very nice yeah that helps me come extra
hard oh edging I thought a genius when
you get to the point oh yeah I mean you
just stop yeah do that like can you do
it a bunch of times that's just sex for
us because I'm like [ __ ] man let's like
laughs a little long I know I'm good
yeah thank you
oh that's good that's so nice that's a
nice edge five times like 60 seconds oh
Jesus no 60 seconds that's willpower Wow
you can last five times you stop
yourself Firenze oh yeah that's a good
way look at it it's like [ __ ] you
know dude
uno what's that game with the thumb with
the [ __ ] I'm [ __ ] them you flip the
thing taboo this guy has not played any
games tabby Oh noona or is just yeah
they're very easy to cut you don't play
many board games I will say they're both
card games but okay
don't settle in me don't send under me I
get it it's fine no I'm good
I get so bored during them we have taboo
and I know we do it reminds me of my
childhood and being very bored while my
dad tries to read all the rules before
we play it that's true your family is
like the work followers or they like to
read no they like to like you yeah they
like to read they like to do all the
boring things they just read the rules
when they for the game it feels like
that well they'll read all the roles
have been it's everyone's still confused
because they zoned out during all the
roles being read the TV's on the
background you're just like maybe they
would be exciting for like let's drive
your family I'm gonna give all students
at all I feel like all students need
some help gained through what are the
side effects
maybe you'll get dependent on it I just
I don't it's like dangerous for kids cuz
they're still developing right so if you
get right that's the new Ritalin I think
if you get it when you're young it makes
it less effective when you're old or it
makes you are there's something about
like getting it an elementary school in
high school where it's like actually you
don't want to take it anymore could
affect your brand at all in their CV why
don't we just drug all the kids I think
that's the kind of are like Teflon just
been dragging everybody nobody that's
what happened to me I don't remember
what it was it did take something for
one month when I was 11 but before
taking it I was like [ __ ] jittery as
[ __ ] I was so talkative I was just like
yeah I annoyed myself like that's how
annoying I was and so after taking this
for a month and it was just like boom
all these like annoying factors shut
down I'm still like that i annoy myself
all the time you should take that no
girl no this was bad well then we need
to ask my mom cuz this conversation
keeps coming up and I keep the
medication dude the other day I set a
personal best record for not being on my
phone because I was at a funeral and so
I couldn't check my phone cuz I thought
it would be a very rude
that's time to be on your phone that
would have been that would have been
well David Letterman did the opening to
the [ __ ] funeral that's it crazy
where John Witherspoon the guy from
Friday yeah and then like Ice Cube was
talking it was like oh my god this is so
sad is that ice cube oh my god this is
oh is that deal who clean is that Chris
Tucker and every time you're like yes it
is
yes it was keep your phone down when
like exciting things happening
yeah but they kept on singing hymns and
[ __ ] it was very yeah it was like a lot
of emotions because we're like like all
the speakers were comedians except for
Ice Cube and they were like just
hilarious
there was also in stand-up sets about
John Witherspoon and then Tom Wayans was
was hilarious yeah but then in between
they'd have like really sad songs and
stuff yeah so like this is just a lot it
was a lot of that's a roller coaster
yeah but but it's always it's we already
cuz we were at his funeral you walk in
there's an open casket oh holy [ __ ]
how'd that feel free cuz I don't you
work with them yeah it sucked it was it
was it was weird cuz I hadn't seen him
it is surreal yeah yeah and and this is
the kicker
I had just sent him a pilot that me and
my buddy Mike wrote for him nine days
before he died for all I know it's one
of the last things here if we died what
if he was so bad he [ __ ] died reading
it God what did you ask his son like
yeah what'd you think yeah I didn't get
to use so everyone was swirling around
them it was like a tornado yeah I follow
Marlon Wayans and I could just tell you
so devastated cuz like maybe the last
six or seven posts are just all about
all the good times they had on the
Wayans brothers show and how much he
means to him so sad yeah he was the man
did yeah Shawn wins did it did some
speaking everyone was cracking like lots
of jokes even JD his son was making tons
of jokes like it was a good impression
yeah really good impression and like he
was like pretending to be him in the box
and stuff yeah like in the coffin yeah
yeah yeah
he's like wrap it up boy and all that
but what I really liked about it and I
feel like take notes if you're about to
die because like this was the way to do
a funeral it was like a celebration of
life awesome like morning of a death
were people crying people were yeah but
they were mostly like happy and laughing
like if you look at all the pictures
from the funeral I know JD just posted
someone's Instagram like everybody is
just like big smiles like because he
just gave so much life and laughter and
just touched everybody so so much in
that way like that uplifting way yes
especially who he is yeah and he was
always doing that guy off camera to so
one of the funniest things about that
guy is he loved money so much and he
cared about getting jobs and getting
money more money yeah and and during the
when Ice Cube was up there he was he
actually got choked up and apologized to
John Witherspoon because he couldn't get
last Friday off the ground like you he
was disappointed that it didn't happen
because he knows that he wanted it cuz
he wants the [ __ ] money it's so funny
guys great yeah awesome yeah and they
played a highlight reel of like all of
his work oh it was really cool like
everybody was was in good spirits oh
yeah I thought it was gonna be at first
because it was it was at Forest Lawn so
it was like gonna be outdoors you know I
left my sunglasses at home and it was
really hot that day but it was in they
have I guess like this church type of
building and in the middle of it and I
was all in there well my favorite things
too when they had like an announcer guy
and after every speaker they would say
thank you to the person and then Ice
Cube finished and he's like thank you
ice mr. cute right yeah right he
probably thought about it both ways like
what I do I mean are you in trouble if
you call my legal name I don't know
what's his legal name I don't even know
wait wait wait wait ice cube sounds
birth name right what is it
I don't know this point some boy Ikaros
q baniyas it's like Dwayne Williams or
something boring like that like when I
found out Dwayne the rock was just
weighing the rhyme like what Dwayne
Johnson so boring yeah
when I find you as the rock yeah you
know what I mean that's like that's like
knowing Batman it's like hey I'm Bruce
Wayne actually it's like nuts on its
form yeah well when I first found out
that Wolverines name was Logan and I was
like really why is that that dumb
because it was like cheap seems like
he's like knives and then is like Logan
all true like because of him I really
like the name Logan really yeah because
he made the name logan really strong for
me but then Logan Paul killed it I'm
mostly new kids in middle school named
Logan and there were little [ __ ] boys
who played by that's what I that's why I
was so committed Logan that's like both
to Logan's that I knew just were really
really nice guys like super super nice
like just people really paint a name for
you yeah ice cubes real name is Shia
Jackson oh yeah not bad actually for
this son play dumb and that's okay
Jackson jr. I don't even know I'm not
allowed to guess or get it wrong I just
keep cracking it every time I'm in a
movie theater and they have a trailer
that Denzel Washington Suns in I hear 17
people around me go like Denzel
Washington son that's Denzel you'd
recognize him if I told you he's in this
new Chris Nolan movie called Tennant
coming up and he was in the trailer he
looks just like that though he looks
very similar very very second like you
are only known as Denzel Washington so
we can't like make your own name he have
the same teeth as Denzel cuz and that's
yes oh [ __ ] yeah
he's people bad no they're just like big
teeth big there was something that was
like there's some headline it was like
Cory Booker's girlfriend accompanies him
to a movie premiere it's [ __ ] rosario
Dawson I think it was I don't know if
they're together anymore to say you know
a little haha
you got the tea girl oh just spilled the
tea on your table
[Music]
[Music]